why do you gravitate towards
storytelling I think that storytelling
is the is what separates us from Beasts
and animals
I think storytelling is what uniquely
defines what it is to be human it is the
oldest thing that we have done apart
from eating and sleeping and dying you
know if we're if we're going back to the
sort of um Fantastical view of the
cro-magna man and prehistoric times
because I know we all kind of put like a
fairy tale glaze over that so having not
lived during that era myself I really
can't comment on the accuracy of what
I'm about to say but
you know even before agriculture there
was a telling of a story even before
words really existed before there was
language it might have been like right
but that could mean hey there's
something over there that I just saw
that in and of itself is a story
so the most human thing is to tell
stories when people ask what I do
because I have a lot of like you've
never written things you've done this
um I just say I'm a Storyteller I say
that I tell stories I am interested in
The Art of Storytelling because it is
the oldest way to connect from one human
to another it is the way that we pass on
our experience if you think about how
um people taught each other 2 000 years
ago it was I will teach you right teach
Amanda fish it goes back to sort of that
kind of stuff five thousand years ago
it's very much a I know how to do this
one skill this agrarian skill and now I
will pass it on to you so
we all do storytelling that's that's
just what I know that's what I get
excited about I think when people get
really you know like I'm gonna go home
I'm done with work and I'm gonna go
watch my favorite show it it triggers
this little spark in us that's been
there for tens of thousands of years
that ultimately is why we are human
beings
um my dog doesn't necessarily tell a
story I love her to bits but you know
she's not going to be like well here's
my day Mom she's just she's
lives in the moment you know a lot of
animals obsessively live in the present
um I mean as far as I know having never
entered the mind of an animal before
um we really are the ones that kind of
ruminate on the past and think towards
the future and I think we have a concept
of time because of our ability to tell
story
singing is telling a story Opera yes it
is that it is
it definitely it's it's telling a story
especially Opera in a really long drawn
out way singing is just talking on
pressurized air it's all it is if you
can speak you can sing there for
everyone out there who thinks they can't
sing yes you can if you can talk we can
talk about that but side note
um
Opera is so interesting because when or
even musical theater because it's just
really elongated speech right if it's
like hello I am he
to tell you a story like terrible
singing just now but the point is is
that it's it's the same level of intent
that I have in in talking to you right
now and trying to get an idea across
it's just like extremely stretched out
right so the different mediums whether
it be a painting which is here is a
story that's being told in a finite
space forever over and over again or
music where it's like here's a really
weird way to tell the story where you
know there might be a standalone song
like a folk song that says a beginning
middle and end or maybe more
contemporary pop where it's like we're
just hearing somebody's inner monologue
but that is also a story
um or film I mean these are all just
different mediums to to do that singing
certainly is a way of telling story
how do you get people invested in a
story
it's a fine line between
making it something that is generally
relatable but with a certain level of
specificity that people are going to be
like
oh my God that's my life
um I'm going to say something and I hope
it is not inflammatory but I find that
this is like how astrology works right
people that really buy into astrology I
think it is fundamentally
vague and specific enough that people
can find like oh wow that really applies
to me in my week
um whether or not that is what is
happening and that's not my place to
comment
um but I think it's the same thing with
storytelling it's um how do we make this
universally relatable but also deeply
specific enough so that I can
try to get people to be like whoa that
was my life story like thank you so much
for capturing that thank you for saying
that because I've never seen my struggle
on the big screen before so thank you
for that I think it's it's walking that
line
that's a great I love how you you
brought up astrology because if you look
at the weekly horoscope right if you
covered up and believe me I I enjoy you
know astrology here it's fun yeah it's
very it's very airy fairy and that's why
I asked the question not that I haven't
called that no never
um but if you if you covered up the
signs it could apply to to all of our
weeks yeah you know a random stranger
will deliver news to you and you're like
oh wow I wonder who that is spicy right
yeah it could have been you were on hold
and the random stranger said you know oh
okay we see that your account blah blah
blah there's the news they're delivering
right any of us right um but it is
interesting how we tap into stories that
very much call to us and and maybe
that's why there is some you know
certain traits are you know inherent in
certain signs but anyway not to go to no
yeah I mean I I completely agree I think
that it's for me it's like the best
thing right it's the best example that I
have and in a lot of ways it's
seem like a marketing and branding nerd
and that's because I am one that's how
marketing works right that's how like
think of a commercial you want it to be
like vague enough that like random
person number five can be like hmm yeah
that's my life but specific enough that
you're positioning the product as the
hero to save the day for your specific
problem so that if someone happens to
actually watch a commercial for once
they'll be like oh wow wow I didn't
realize I needed that okay now you've
planted the seed and the next time that
problem emerges they're probably going
to go buy that product
it's um the story yeah storytelling is
vague and specific all at once it's a
bizarre line to walk do you have a
favorite commercial
from the past that's a really good
question that's a really good question I
feel like Through the Ages they all have
such a different vibe
um I have different ones that I love for
like there are ones that I love because
they're memes and they're hysterical at
this point like things from the 70s and
80s where you're like wow that was a
really heavy-handed way to talk about
this product or like the 90s there's the
90s I feel like was the era of Jingles
that never left your head which are I
still could sing really rare like Baby
Bottle Pop I could like bust that one
out right now
um in terms of recent commercials
this isn't a favorite one but it sticks
out to me just because it was like let's
smack you in the face with sorrow Google
has a product and I don't even know what
it actually is called that's what's so
funny about this is the ad stuck with me
because the story was like oh my God but
I don't even know the name of the
product like Google memory or Google I'm
going to incept your brain Memories
Forever but it basically is like
you could put in all of like the shared
stories or photos of memories of a
person and then like be able to look at
that or like even chat with that person
in such a like with an AI construct of
that person in a way so that when they
pass I don't know that I understand the
product you can see that I'm like now
telling you a Sci-Fi story all I know is
that the ad destroyed me because it was
like someone who was reliving talking to
their grandfather who had passed or like
their old late husband who passed or
something like that it just came up in
the Super Bowl and I was like not
emotionally prepared Super Bowl ads for
me are usually like this is silly and we
spent millions of dollars on it but this
one was like let's just Bunch you in
your Fields oh so it was emotional they
really got so emotional but to a degree
that it was like a Pixar movie where I'm
like wow I'm really not like you just
are you're just having a field day with
my emotions
yeah it was crazy yeah but that's great
now I'm going to start looking at
commercials as like
little bits I mean it is I don't know
why it's never clicked for me but it
really is little bits of stories well
and as an actor like the script they
always call the product the hero
that's how it's positioned so it's the
same thing as a theatrical script it's
just that the hero of the story is like
Cheez-Its instead of a person